نتواجد الان على رصيف ميناء بورت سودان
النقطه الاخيره التي يتم بعدها تصعيد
الرعايه المتواجدين والذي يتم اجراءات
انهاء اجراءات سفرهم من التاشيرات
والجوازات عبر المسؤولون السعوديون
المتواجدون هنا في الميناء نتحدث عن خليه
دبلوماسيه في هذا الميناء وايضا خارج هذا
الميناء تقوم بها الحكومه السعوديه
لاجلاء رعايه من عده دول مختلفه كما
تشاهدون الان يتم انهاء اجراءات السفر عبر
تفتيش الشنط الخاصه بالمسافرين عبر
الميناء يتم نقلهم عبر قوارب الى السفن
المتوقفه بالقرب من هذا الميناء نتحدث عن
سفينتين ستبحر مساء هذا اليوم تحمل عدد من
الرعايه الذين ستقل لهم الى الميناء جده
الاسلام من قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه بجده
يصل يوميا الى هذا الميناء ما يقرب من عشر
حافلات تقل عدد من الرعايه من ولايات
السودان المختلفه يتم التنسيق هنا مع
سفارات بلدان الرعايه الذين سيغادرون عبر
هذا الميناء ايضا بالتنسيق مع هيئه
الموانع السودانيه والجهات المتواجده في
الميناء السعودي تتحدث عن ان عمليات
الاجلاء ما تزال مستمره وتستمر حتى انتهاء
النزاع المسلح في السودان
الربيعان الجزيره من ميناء بورت سودان